bonjour merci de nous avoir rejoints
dans file echo l'émission qui revient
sur l'actualité économique locale on
commence tout de suite avec les titres
de cette émission six cent mille foyers
privés de gaz d'électricité c'est le
lourd chiffre qu'avance la cgt avec la
fin de la trêve hivernale nous
écouterons les annonces du syndicat et
de erdf
en parallèle du salon de l'automobile de
genève découverte de la nouvelle
citadine de renault la twingo iii
axel et maria poursuivre leur projet de
création d'entreprise lui lance une
brasserie locale elle est née au
crêperie nous les suivons depuis octobre
où en sont ils réponse dans notre
dossier la semaine et puis nous
parlerons des business angels et
particuliers qui finance la création et
le développement des entreprises en ile
de france des réseaux se développe alors
qu'ils sont ils commencent ou tient-il
l'entrepreneuriat réponse avec nos deux
invités bruno duplessis degré là dans
bonjour vous êtes membre du réseau in
vst sort face à vous nous avons jadis
jamie le meurin excusez-moi animatrice
du réseau invest y en jazz on vous
retrouve dans quelques minutes mais
avant sa place à l'actualité économique
de la semaine
le 1er novembre le gouvernement a mis en
place une trêve hivernale pour les
fournisseurs de gaz et d'électricité à
l'image de celle que connaît le logement
jusqu'au 15 mars il n'avait pas le droit
de priver d'énergie les mauvais payeurs
mais la date approche et la cgt alerte
sur la reprise des coupures cela fait
quelques mois que la liste des foyers
concernés s'accumulent six cent mille
selon leurs sources pour le secrétaire
général de la cgt énergie de bagneux la
situation est critique
les directions ont cherché des
paillettes il fallait soit était d
entraide entre services pour trouver des
effectifs de salariés qui regroupées
soit des recours à des prestataires ou à
des intérimaires par exemple à grdf ce
sont des intérimaires qui vont aller
faire les prestations de coupure donc
quand on a eu c'est la foule a
effectivement constaté qu'il y allait
avoir une recrudescence des découpures
paraît évident à la cgt souhaiterait que
les salariés est un droit de retrait
puisque refusé de couper le gaz ou
l'électricité militent pour un droit à
l'énergie de son côté erdf cherche à
rassurer sur ces données notre situation
sur quatre on trouve des solutions
palliatives à la coupures pour impayés
si en général un accompagnement
deux foyers qui en a besoin un
accompagnement si on peut les mettre en
rapport avec le ccas de la commune on
peut les mettre en rapport avec le
conseil général qui gère le fonds de
solidarité logement
donc on a mis à dispo en place des
dispositifs avec les fournisseurs
lorsqu'un technicien de erdf va procéder
à la coupure qui est demandé par un
fournisseur il a une hotline il peut
appeler cette hotline pour faire pour
signaler une situation
de précarité qui n'avait pas été
détectée par les fournisseurs en amont
et donc à ce moment là nous ne procédons
pas la coupure alors on continue dans ce
secteur d'activité la cité des métiers
de saint quentin en yvelines a lancé la
semaine de l'énergie depuis lundi elle
organise des réunions d'information sur
les métiers mais aussi des visites
d'entreprises
aujourd'hui le siège social de bouygues
énergie au service par exemple un
bâtiment écologique hier la centrale
thermique de porcheville et mardi
c'était au tour de erdf de participer à
cette semaine des images de patrick
jacques de dixmude
mardi l' agence de conduite régionale de
erdf a ouvert ses portes à guyancourt
tout au long de l'après midi une
trentaine de personnes est venue
découvrir les locaux mais surtout les
métiers spécifiques aux réseaux de
distribution d'électricité dont cette
agence les 25 salariés se charge du bon
fonctionnement du réseau sur trois
départements les yvelines les hauts de
seine et le val d'oise ici ou sur le
terrain les besoins de erdf reste
toujours important 1700 personnes ont
été recrutées en 2013 et nos métiers de
base il faut continuer à les assurer le
dépannage
l'exploitation de nos réseaux
l'entretien de nos réseaux donc on
recrute des personnels techniques de
plus en plus féminin essayer d'en avoir
ses pâtures facile mais aussi à de
nouveaux métiers qui apparaissent
notamment autour de tout ce qu'ils aient
raison intelligent on pense notamment au
déploiement du compteur linky qui permet
de relever la consommation et la
production est d'intervenir à distance
parmi les visiteurs mardi des
professionnels de l'orientation des
chefs d'entreprise et bien sûr des
demandeurs d'emploi comme blick comme je
suis ingénieur en environnement en
recherche d'emploi donc je voulais voir
un peu tout les perspectives et
notamment ce qui m'a intéressé c'est
la fonction hygiène sécurité
environnement
j'ai déposé un cv donc ce sera à eux de
voir un peu si mon profil correspond à
leur attente dont les yvelines lagence
envisage de recruter une trentaine de
personnes cette année notamment via
l'apprentissage
dévoilé officiellement au salon
automobile de genève la nouvelle twingo
s'exposer aussi au technocentre renault
de guyancourt
l'occasion pour les salariés du
constructeur de découvrir cette nouvelle
citadine des images de jonathan vilma
vingt ans après la sortie de la première
twingo renault sort une nouvelle version
de cette citadine la troisième du nom un
gabarit réduit un design qui se veut
joyeux le constructeur automobile veut
renouer avec les fondamentaux du modèle
de 1993 renault a présenté
officiellement la twingo iii au salon
automobile de genève pour ses
collaborateurs elle a exposé quelques
pré modèle au technocentre de guyancourt
ça rajeunit je pense la twingo 2 super
mignonne où très compacte
assez fun
je pense qu'il va bien plus armée femmes
les femmes un des publics qu'on touchait
le constructeur tout comme les jeunes et
pour cela renault a misé sur une plus
grande praticité 5 portes au lieu de
trois un design plus moderne et des
possibilités de personnalisation par
exemple l'ajout de couleur dans
l'habitacle ou de stripping sur les
ailes et pour la génération connectée la
possibilité de transformer son téléphone
portable en véritables tablettes
interactives avec lecteur radio mais
aussi navigation 3d ou encore
informations relatives à la conduite
autre nouveauté et pas des moindres le
moteur est cette fois situé à l'arrière
du véhicule il ya vraiment deux
bénéfices majeurs pour le client avec
cette architecture arrière c'est la
grande habitabilité
et la compacité extérieur ça les arrange
peut citer deux chiffres cette voiture
là lé 10 cm plus courte par rapport à
twingo 2 extérieurement et à l'intérieur
de la boîte à gants jusqu'à l'arrière
jusqu'au seuil de coffre on va retrouver
22 centimètres de plus autre raison son
alliance avec daimler les deux
constructeurs collaborent sur ce système
pour partager les coûts de production
délocalisée en slovénie la petite
citadine devrait être commercialisée en
septembre à près de dix mille au
la maison de l'emploi centre et sud
yvelines tire la sonnette d'alarmé ses
dirigeants s'inquiètent de la baisse des
subventions de l'état pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas ce type de structure il
s'agit d'un établissement public qui
vise à soutenir l'emploi et à aider les
chômeurs mais aussi les salariés et les
entreprises les subventions de l'état
sont passées de 70 30 à 70 40 % le reste
étant pris en charge par les
collectivités locales et un rembourrage
crains que cela ne continue de baisser
le nouveau cahier des charges a déjà
restreint les missions des maisons de
l'emploi alors quel avenir pour ces
organismes c'est ce que se demande le
président de la maison de l'emploi de
rambouillet au micro de julien leroy il
faut savoir déjà que en 2006 lorsqu on a
créé
lorsqu'a été validés a été labellisé la
maison de l'emploi
le pas la partition la participation de
l'état était de 70% dans notre budget et
de tenez donc la participation des
collectivités locales simplement de 30%
ce budget à l'époque était de 5 123
mille et quelques euros et si on
observe de près ce qui va nous arriver
donc dans l'est dans les prochains mois
il serait tombé seulement à 101 milles
euros ce qui évidemment mais en
difficulté
notre notre structure alors à chatou les
vignes à la maison de l'emploi à mons à
118 par le même de fermeture possible en
2015 à 50 ans livre une cependant on se
veut plus rassurant les missions seront
maintenus cette année parce que je me
rends à l'entretien
midi sonne
ça y est nous y sommes les business
angels et particuliers qui aident au
financement et à la création
d'entreprises
alors ils se regroupent parfois en
réseau nous avons modifié de bel exemple
bruno duplessis de grenade en vous êtes
membre du réseau in vst sort et nous
avons également une représentante du
réseau invest y angels jeanine meurin
alors jeanine meurin vous organisiez cet
après midi une réunion d'information à
destination des entrepreneurs qui
cherchent à financer leurs projets
vouloir indiquer qu'un business angels
est souvent un entrepreneur frustré
qu'est ce que vous voulez dire par là
sont eux qui vivent ou ils ont été
entrepreneur et il
continue d'une certaine manière à
entreprendre à travers les autres
quelquefois ils sont encore d'activité
meilleurs donc ils passent de leur
expérience et
ses 2 c'est vraiment de la m et de la
transmission du transfert mais c'est
vrai qu'il y en a qui ont eu une belle
carrière
des ingénieurs en particulier qui aurait
aimé entreprendre et qu'ils le font à
travers d'autres alors il ya également
une troisième raison peut-être c'est
aussi un moyen de placer son argent oui
c'est sa moyenne diversification c'est
sans aucun doute
après avoir investi dans quelques
appartements et non des actions en
bourse qui ne sont pas prêts sécurisés
ont fait quelque chose d'utile en
accompagnant une entreprise et en
investissant dans une entreprise et
comme on a eu quelques belles réussites
c'est encouragent ces risques et ces
risques est également il ya sûrement des
réductions d'impôts à l'entrée ou à la
sortie du capital alors vous
du plessis de grenade en de votre côté
qu'est ce qui vous a poussé finalement à
vous lancer dans un réseau de business
angels d'abord j'ai été effectivement
créateur d'une société à quelqu'un un
petit bisbilles entre créateurs à
arrêter une aventure et après gessier
seul de m'occuper d'entreprise en tant
que bea j'ai réalisé que ce l'on pouvait
rien faire donc je suis venu dans un
réseau un peu de ça ont raison on est
plus forts alors je précise béal
business angels en raison n'est plus
forcément des plus forts on fédère les
compétences et quentin instruit un
dossier on se complète alors la
sélection est rude sur l'année
finalement combien d'eau si vous recevez
et combien sont finalement réellement et
nous aidons 2% sur un peu plus de 1000
dossiers vingt dossiers par an seront
financés
très petit d'un très petit chiffre c'est
la même façon à
2% ça me semble correct également
il faut savoir aussi que reçoit beaucoup
de ciels il y en a quelques-uns qui sont
pas éligibles du tout un après on fait
des choix en fonction de nos affinités
en fonction de ce qu'on comprend de ce
qu'on peut faire aussi on peut pas tout
faire il ya la localisation il ya
l'intérêt il ya la diversification du
portefeuille
quand on possède déjà donc il ya plein
critères mais ça ne veut pas dire puis
il ya aussi des dossiers avec lesquels
on appelle affinités ou ça veut pas dire
que les dossiers sent mauvais
il ya en ile de france plus de 20
réseaux voire 25 un dossier peut ne pas
plaire à un réseau et trouver son
bonheur dans un autre réseau et faire
des heureux d'ailleurs le premier réseau
peut aider à finaliser et accompagner la
réflexion et le dossier va arriver dans
un second réseau plus mature et est du
coup être plus séduisant
justement là un bel exemple l'entreprise
donc blanc crème guidés par nicolas
guilbert donc et c'est d'abord proposé
dans votre réseau de business angels il
finale finalement il lancé en saint
germain en laye un magasin de produits
cosmétiques il ya quelques années il
adore d'investissement de départ de
50000 euros en fonctionnement assez
artisanal mais bien vite finalement le
succès est arrivé les investissements au
moins ok je vous propose d'écouter cette
période de sa vie il a finalement trouvé
un financement auprès de votre faux pas
votre fonds d'investissement et votre
réseau de business angel rond l'écoutent
et donc on s'est retrouvé à livrer le
printemps haussmann beauty monop et
nocibé dont 11 mètres carrés de labo à
l'arrière boutique à stocker les
produits chez l'opticien de la rue celle
agences immobilières donc très vite on
s'est rendu compte que la marque percer
un peu plus que la boutique qui était
dans une situation compliquée d'une
ville qui était un réaménagement à
l'époque et donc on a décidé de
capitaliser sur ce qu'on savait faire
puisque nous au départ on est des
marketeurs on n'est pas des commerçants
donc on est on est reparti sur la marque
mais pour ça une fois les
investissements donc on a fermé la
boutique il après il a fallu qu'on
achète des machines on a refait tous les
packagings puisqu'on a mis des
étiquettes français et anglais avec des
codes barres pour pouvoir être vendus
chez les autres refait tout le site web
créer des étuis
embauché du monde trouvez les
commerciaux en finlande à une équipe de
20 personnes donc vous pouvez pas passer
de 2 à 20 sans financement alors donc il
a cherché donc du coût des financements
auprès de plusieurs réseaux il a
finalement trouvé preneur il a eu 70 76
mille euros l'année dernière avec une
veste et soeur ils exposent porte
aujourd'hui aux usa au canada en espagne
ou encore au maroc il a 150 boutiques en
france dont cinq dans département alors
il cherche de nouveau des fonds deux
cent mille euros aujourd'hui il est ce
soir dans une séance plénière alors
qu'est ce qu'une séance plénière
finalement dans votre réseau nous les
membres du réseau sont présents et les
entrepreneurs ont quinze minutes pour
exposer leur projet et ils ont quinze
minutes de questions-réponses
au vu de saint lô bea décident s'ils ont
l'intention de suivre le dossier et si
nous sommes suffisamment nombreux à
suivre le dossier nous continuons à
l'instruction vous vouliez à plusieurs
personnes pour avoir le financement
il faut qu'un dossier sont intéressants
pour qu'ils puissent être financés alors
quelle différence finalement avec un
fonds d'investissement ou un financement
un prêt bancaire par exemple parce que
en fait un fonds d'investissement va
plutôt regarder le côté financier la
rentabilité la rentabilité l'aebea le
retarde aussi mais ils vont aider
l'entrepreneur et nous avons des cas
d'entrepreneurs que pour lequel le nous
sommes aillent voir et rapidement on a
réussi même
ne pas faire le moins de capital parce
que en le réorganisant ils ont trouvé
l'argent dans leurs activités c'est un
cas extrême mais ça existe et
alors d'ailleurs le rappel en business
angels comme comme l'indiqué
alors plus en détail comment se fait
finalement la sélection pour l'un et
l'autre
je pense qu'elle est identique dans tous
les réseaux
des nuances vraiment un film les
dossiers arrivent par internet le plus
souvent maintenant il n'y a plus de
dossiers qui nous arrive par la poste
c'est arrivé il ya 15 ans donc tout
arrive par internet ils sont lus et la
première sélection se fait à la lecture
vous confirmez voilà donc la première
sélection se fait la lecture et ensuite
le dossier alors
je vais parler pour moi je sais comment
ça se passe bien mais c'est ça donc
ensuite si le dossier est intéressant
nous invitons l'entrepreneur un comité
de sélection où il va présenter son
dossier de présentation d'un produit que
cassard et vert et où on va faire
une première question réponse mais c'est
aussi une façon de rencontrer
l'entrepreneur puisqu'on disait
l'entrepreneur fait tout donc nous nous
souhaitons avoir cette rencontre
seulement voilà et puis voir comment ils
écoutent nos questions comment il répond
aussi voir comment et puis et puis ça
continue comme ça très si si tout ça est
positif on va en plénière et après on
instruit en plénière des du coup comme
vous l'expliqué alors je crois que c'est
une veste et sort c'est à peu près des
finances fonds de 200 millions d'euros y
est vous même vous avez participé à une
quinzaine de projets qui exactement donc
c'est resté aussi risqué j'ai eu
aujourd'hui 3 en faillite mais beaucoup
de plaisir à suivre c'est un
entrepreneur et on espère que vous
enverrez encore beaucoup merci beaucoup
à tous les deux d'avoir été présent sur
notre plateau on passe tout de suite au
décès la semaine
petit souci technique mais nous y sommes
alors pour le dossier nous retrouvons
axel courson et maria gaffney de
guyancourt toi qui se sont lancés dans
la création d'entreprise justement il
lance une bière locale elle ouvre une
crêperie et leurs deux projets prennent
forme comme vous allez le voir dans ce
troisième volet un reportage réalisé
avec elodie moines julien leroy et
romain respini
pour maria le projet avance cela fait
près de six mois qu'elle a repris la
crêperie du village à guyancourt les
travaux ont bien démarré elle découvre
aujourd'hui la nouvelle devanture
à peine le temps de jeter un coup d'oeil
que des commerciaux en cidre breton
viennent la démarche et maria mc
rencontre fortuite peut-être le début
d'une aventure commerciale c'était bien
ça en apéritif de bienvenue
ouais
féminin
la crêperie devrait ouvrir d'ici fin
mars une date qui approche à grands pas
son ami axel partage son empressement il
a rencontré maria alors d'une formation
en création d'entreprise et depuis il
s'entraîne dans leurs projets la
restauratrice fait découvrir les lieux
ici la salle de plonge
bien elle super lent elle est vraiment
super vallée et je le sais une belle
s'est pas mis des noms pour et monfils
certainement les deux amis devraient
devenir partenaire la spécialité du
jeune guyancourt toi le brassage de
bière un produit que l'on devrait
retrouver sur la carte de marjah en
attendant que cela se concrétise
axel cherche à démarcher les
professionnels du coin
parmi les gérants de bars qui la
démarche et en compte sébastien fargeau
il connaît axel depuis une dizaine
d'années ils font partie du même club
local de rugby et il tient
l'établissement à voisin un partenaire
tout trouvé l'objectif c'est qu'on
développe son produit qu'on l'aide à se
lancer et puis nous on prend aucun
risque avant d'en à vendre sa bière quoi
en prenant des quantités par caisse si
on les vend pas d'un seul coup ça se
fera au fur et à mesure et qui sait ça
marche pas pour nous nous on veut dire
on a aucun risque là dedans sébastien
souhaite aider son ami mais dans les
autres bars et restaurants des environs
axel ne devrait pas non plus avoir trop
de mal à vendre ses bières l'aspect
local de son produit pelé à de nombreux
professionnels j'ai pas eu de
déconvenues en allant voir des bars ou
des restaurants c'est plutôt d accueil
positif c'est un peu un test sur un
nouveau ballon qui va donner des notes
un peu d'agrumes donc c'est une guerre
qui va être candidate pour la future
bière à la future 5u donc c'est un avis
dessus de moi
effectivement il ya des bouts je me suis
dit d'agrumes dans les très très bonne
le seul fait que c'est que voilà on n'a
pas eu le temps peut-être là la boire un
peu plus plus fraîches sébastien
préférera la bière de noël un autre
produit que tu est le brasseur cette
séance de dégustation est aussi
l'occasion pour eux de parler stratégie
commerciale les affiches sont des choses
qu'on peut coller qu'il ya là par
exemple sera palette mais etc
qui a vu sur les
autres bars autre décor axel retrouve
cette fois maria elle aussi futur
collaboratrice et on est d'accord sur
une telle
sera
la 5 8 n'est pas bretonne mais locales
et devrait trouver sa clientèle dans la
crêperie du village ces retrouvailles
sont aussi l'occasion de parler de
l'avancement de leurs projets respectifs
et là tous deux font face aux mêmes
problèmes cela fait trois mois qu'ils
attendent l'argent de leurs prêts nacre
une somme essentielle pour débloquer
leurs prêts bancaires mais le gros
problème crous et que
ne peut pas commander ses plumes et
moi j'ai payé tout avec mes venir donc
il ya moins
portés travaux il va un moment mais j'ai
déjà payé moi j'ai payé avec les deniers
avec non seulement des prêts de la
banque n'était pas pour les 3,6 mais
c'était beau mais c'était ça ou
alors jour avaient
un risque assumé continuer les travaux
assez frais pour ne pas retarder
davantage l'ouverture de son restaurant
mais axel de son côté n'a pas assez de
fonds propres pour avancer les frais
liés à son matériel un mois plus tard
fin de la galère le prêt bancaire vient
d'être débloquée mais le jeune brasseur
a pris du retard sur son calendrier
bilan un mois et demi de décalage pour
commencer à lancer son commerce axel a
trouvé une parade un système assez
artisanal à moindre coût mon objectif
actuellement là c'était vraiment de
pouvoir produire quelque chose avec une
installation qui ne coûte pas trop cher
puisque j'ai l'autre qui va arriver donc
je voulais pas mettre de 3000 euros dans
une installation que je pourrais pas
rentabiliser le temps et le temps plus
tard j'ai fait j'ai fait cette
installation là ça m'a coûté ma coûté
400 euros parce que c'est des tréteaux
une planche en bois départ d'un
autre système dé une perceuse pour
moudre le maïs pour le moment il brasse
une bière de printemps de quoi tenir
jusqu'à l'arrivée des plus grandes cuves
est un moyen de démarcher dès maintenant
les professionnels et les particuliers
et pour cela il organise début mars la
crémaillère de son local il proposera
des précommandes au moins vingt cartons
ça sera une belle
20 cartons pour cette soirée cela
représente 80 litres de bière avec cette
installation
il compte en produire et en vendre 200
litres par semaine
quelques jours plus tard nous retrouvons
axel pour sa crémaillère le premier
événement public de son entreprise le
but c'est vraiment commencé à la faire
connaître à des particuliers à des amis
de la famille les gens qui ont gravité
autour du projet ça permet de tester
voilà comment comment on peut recevoir
dans la patrie et comment je peux
organiser une dégustation et accueillir
tout le monde à terme axel compte
recevoir du public dans son local et
faire des démonstrations de brassage en
direct des visites pédagogiques qu'il
teste à moindre échelle aujourd'hui en
fait le maltage c'est un processus papa
tu peux le faire sur de l'or je peux le
faire sur doublé ses comptes qui fait
germer en vo et sécher je fermais ouais
après tu sèches mais cette soirée est
surtout l'occasion pour les invités de
découvrir sa bière des retours plutôt
positif bien je trouve qu'elle a ses 12
je m'attendais à une pierre un peu plus
forte le fait qu'elle soit qu'elles
soient artisanale mais non les très
bonnes et très agréable bord les
commandes s'enchaînent l'objectif des 80
litres est vite atteint
pour accompagner la bière axel a
forcément penser à son amie maria
aujourd'hui elle prend la peau du
traiteur un moyen pour elles aussi de
faire découvrir sa néo crêperie
et on leur souhaite que ça continue
et on finit donc avec l'agenda si les
aventures de maria et axel vous ont
donné envie de vous lancer dans la
création d'entreprise
la chambre de commerce de versailles
organise un forum le 18 mars vous
pourrez rencontrer des experts de la
chambre échanger avec des créateurs
rendez vous donc de 16 heures à 20
heures les ateliers individuels et
thématiques auront lieu toute la soirée
tout le programme sur le site de la cci
vinh et puis toujours à la chambre de
versailles une réunion d'information
gratuite sur la reprise d'entreprise au
programme des données sur le marché de
la reprise et ses opportunités les
démarches à suivre et les offres de
formation cela se déroule le 21 mars de
9h30 à 11h30 à versailles c'est la fin
de ce fil est qu merci de nous avoir
rejoints on se retrouve dans une semaine
et d'ici là n'oubliez pas ce week-end en
raison du pic de pollution les
transports sont gratuits